William neil moore
pled guilty to murder in the commission of an armed robbery in 1974 and was
sentenced to death in Georgia.
He spent 16 and a half years on death row.
Eight times execution dates were set to carry out his execution.
He once came within seven hours of being executed by the state of Georgia.
Uh,
I want to welcome him.
And why don't you start Mr more by just telling us how it was that you were
sentenced to death.
Um,
I committed a murder and armed robbery and I pled guilty.
My family hired a lawyer that they pay $9,000 to and after he had came to the
county jail to talk to me,
he said,
well,
I seen a confession and basically nothing I can do about it,
but my brother is a judge and we will talk to this other guy.
And you plead guilty and we could chill life sentence.
So on July 17th,
1974 when I went into the courtroom and to plead guilty when the judge came in
the courtroom.
Actually he already,
he actually already had my death sentence typed up before we even went to trial.
Um,
wasn't much of a trial.
He was a prosecutor actually basically rehearsing my confession,
everything that I said.
And uh,
after that,
the judge asked my attorney,
what is your defense?
And he said,
drama.
We plead guilty,
talked to Billy.
And I got on the stand explaining to the judge how wrong I was.
I Sar was,
I gave the money back.
And the reason why I pled guilty because I was in fact guilty when I,
that I did not mean to commit the murder,
but I'm totally responsible.
And he said,
did I did a good and honorable thing and they giving him the money back by
pleading guilty.
But on Friday the 13th of 1974,
I'll be taken to the state prison and execute it.
All right,
let me back you up just a little.
Tell us just a little about the crime and about how you felt after you had
committed it.
Well,
committing a crime was,
first of all was into financial need in which is not an excuse.
There's never an excuse for murder.
But the background information is,
I was trying to get some money to be able to take care of my son and I met this
guy and he said he knew a man.
He kept $30,000 in his house and we can take it.
So,
uh,
the plan,
nobody was to get hurt.
We just take the money.
But in the course of trying to get the money,
uh,
Mr Staple,
when it came out in his bedroom with the shotgun and the chug on bro hit me in
the leg and it scared him and he fired the shotgun and it scared me enough,
fired a pistol and I shot him and killed him.
And um,
after that,
it was like 30,
40 minutes.
I'm back at my trailer.
I'm sitting here,
let me ask you,
is you've under the influence of any
alcohol or drugs?
Yeah,
we are.
We smoked a lot of pot and drink a whole fifth of Jack Daniels.
I mean to,
to commit any type of crime.
Uh,
most guys get high because you're conscious,
you know,
a person doesn't have to be religious to know what is right and wrong.
Your conscious tells you.
And the reason why people get high before they commit crimes,
and so that they can stop hearing that voice in the back of their mind,
nagging the,
and telling them this is wrong.
Don't do it.
Because if you do it,
you gonna get in trouble.
And so to negate that you get high and so that you can go ahead and do what you
know you shouldn't do.
And after you were arrested,
you gave a full confession.
I gave it two and a half hour confession to the Gbi.
He said to me,
Georgia Bureau of Investigation,
yeah,
he said to me,
um,
if you are so sorry about the crime,
then why don't you tell us about it?
And I said,
okay,
God,
I tell you everything that I can remember.
What was so reposting and shocking to me was the fact that while I'm telling
them,
it's like I'm really seeing it for the first time myself.
Actually what I actually did,
and it's just hard to deal with the fact that I had shot someone and and killed
somebody for some money.
Now later you,
uh,
B you got the police reports and so forth in the case,
is that right?
Yeah,
after uh,
being sentenced to death and the judge telling me that I'm going to be executed
on Friday and you're 13,
well,
my lawyer didn't explain any anything to me about there being a pill process.
So,
you know,
Friday,
September,
Friday the 13th,
I'm sitting on my bed waiting to be executed and nobody shows up.
And so I'm thinking I'm be executed Saturday or Sunday.
So you just waiting,
we just anticipation for the guards and every time you hear him and then they
just pass by and don't send it to me.
Monday,
they give me a letter and my lawyer's like,
oh Golly,
I forgot to tell you that you're not going to be executed on Friday the 13th.
Your cases going on the appeal.
And,
um,
I need you to tell your sister to give me $3,000 to do this.
So I was pretty upset at that and I told my sister,
listened,
you fired this guy and then I will represent myself.
And in doing so,
I filed a petition to the court and got my transcript and a police report came
along with the transcript and he's doing,
I was going through the police report,
I saw all the names of the members of the victim's family.
And I knew at that point did I had to try to do something.
You can't bring a person back,
you can't help.
But in apologizing,
it really helps.
So I wrote the family and ask them if they could find it in her heart to forgive
me,
I would appreciate it.
And,
and to my surprise,
within the next week,
I began to get letters back and they told me that they did forgive me.
And actually that started a correspondence with the victim's family.
And I write letters for the whole 16 and a half years that I was on death row.
And how
many letters did you write there initially to the victim's families?
There's about 30 letters.
About 30 letters.
Yeah.
And you told each one of them?
I told each one I'm individual individually that I was sorry.
And if they could find it in their heart to be giving me.
I appreciate it.
And I got letters back from just about everybody.
And you remained in correspondence with them throughout the time and are you
still in touch with them today?
Even to this day?
We,
uh,
talked about telephone,
I have been down to rinse to visit him a couple of times and their family.
Right.
They're like your family.
Yes.
And we should put this where this case took place.
This was in the ton of Lewisville,
which was in Jefferson County,
Georgia.
And you were serving in the military,
you and Augusta,
Georgia and what?
You were in Fort Benning?
Fort Gordon Ford.
Gordon,
I'm sorry,
Fort Gordon,
right?
Yeah,
that's in Columbus.
Fort Benning.
And um,
uh,
touched this a little bit about your military career.
Well,
I that joined the army because I wanted to get away from the people in the
neighborhood because the neighborhood was violent.
You know,
when,
uh,
I didn't want to go to jail.
They want to get messed up on drugs.
I had friends,
it was getting killed and we're going to prison.
And I said,
well,
I'm getting away from all of that and just joined the military and make a career
out of that.
Where you were from Columbus,
Ohio,
Columbus,
Ohio.
Yes.
And,
um,
I really,
really liked the military.
I mean,
I,
it was help for me because I think it gave me the discipline and sorta like the
fatherly advice that I didn't get because my father went to prison when I was
four,
so he wasn't there.
And so,
uh,
to me
also is like a game.
Everything to me at that time was sort of like a game.
I'm always going to be the best at it and do the best that I could.
And so I liked the,
the physicality of the military.
I liked the fact that,
um,
I will take you to different countries and places that I would never go if I
wasn't in the military,
were just serve before you came to Fort Gordon.
I served three years in Germany.
I was,
uh,
Xcel is trained to be a heavy equipment operator and I really didn't want to do
that in Germany.
So they let me out today,
allow me to Oj t as a military police.
So first I worked in a stuck aid as a guard for 16 months and then I worked as
the mail clerk because I told the captain of the prison did,
I didn't like that type of job being a guard.
It bothered me having to lock of the soldiers up and uh,
I felt that I wanted to be somewhere where I could sort of help them.
And being a male clerk,
I felt that I was,
could help them with getting mail and getting people in their visiting list.
And so that helped.
Then our company moved from Frankfurt to often,
we switched with another company and when we switched,
they moved me to the seven oh ninth.
And big company to send me your exactly right back to Frankfurt where I was in
the beginning.
And in that company,
uh,
that's where you've worked on the streets.
So you had actually been the equivalent of a prison guard while you were in the
military
prison guard,
uh,
police.
Yep.
And when you came to death row,
you now had a very different relationship with the guards.
Yeah,
cause I was the inmate and they were the guards.
But I think that experience of being a guard really helped me understand of how
to relate to them and to,
and to be able to talk with them,
especially when you have guards that are always mean and,
and uh,
wanting to do stuff to inmates.
Being able to explain to other guys while,
you know,
you got to understand that this is the only job that this guy can get it.
Uh,
most of the guys that are guards couldn't,
could make it as police officers couldn't pass those tests stuff.
So now they're here.
So they're like a police,
but the,
not the police did they want it to be,
or a highway patrolman.
And they got an attitude about it.
And so you have to learn how to,
to deal with them.
And I think the only thing that really helps them is when you show them respect
for who they are as a person and their position.
And you did that while you were yeah,
I did it all the time because I was on the other side as being a guard in the
military.
Now you came very close to execution.
Could you tell us about that?
Yes.
In 1984,
uh,
I had lost all of my pills and I got an execution date for May the 24th,
1984 actually judge Mcmillan's sit me,
and this was sort of crazy cause he sent me a letter and an execution date.
He sent me a letter and in the letter he said that he did not want to set a
date,
but the attorney general's office was pressing him to set a date.
So he set this date that he setting,
he's given me the maximum amount of time that he can,
that he waited two months before he said it.
And then he gave me the maximum amount of time in setting it.
He said,
did he did everything,
did he could in,
in doing this?
I mean,
he could have just changed it and it gave me a life sentence.
He could have did that.
But this is,
I dunno,
this was here,
I guess he felt like he was cleaning his sore or something
for say the maximum amount of time.
You mean from the date of the order until the date in which you'd be executed?
Yes.
He give you as much time,
most times the law.
Loud.
And,
and,
and he was saying that he held off two months.
Right.
They just harassed him for two months before he did that.
And,
and so,
um,
I said,
all right.
So I knew that this was common cause,
so I had the date before the state head d day.
And so when they came and said,
okay,
um,
uh,
this is the 21st of May,
you've got an execution date for the 24th.
Uh,
they took him,
packed all my stuff up and took me to the captain's office and say,
here's the execution warrant.
We want you to read it and tell us,
you understand we're going to kill you.
It on the 24th at 12:00 PM,
you understand that this is what the state is ordered.
And they wanted me to sign it.
And then also they say,
well okay,
here's another form.
What do you want us to do with your bottom?
We kill you do,
we can bury you here at the state,
at the cemetery to state has or your family can come and get your body and then
you have to sign another form is who do you want to be the chaplain with you now
they idea was you can choose from their captains and they had like,
like five and none of their chapters really did anything in interacting with us
on death row.
And so when I read what the rules was,
I told him one of the rules so I can have any chocolate.
It doesn't specify as did they have to work here?
So Wharton,
the captain and I went round and round when I told him that I was going to call
my lawyer and we file a lawsuit and that would get this execution stayed.
And they said,
okay,
you just have whoever you want.
And I saw,
I asked for my friend Murphy Davis who works in Atlanta who represented,
well she's not a lawyer,
but she helps death row inmates and sister,
she,
she's a mentor and Minister.
Right,
right,
right.
And so,
uh,
after that they take all your clothes and give you a jumpsuit and said,
this is the one we're going to execute you in a new pair of boots.
It no strings,
no belt.
And then I was taking the death watch.
That is a sale that is like a regular sale.
But there's two officers that sit right in front of it that record your every
move,
every single thing that you say and do for those 72 hours is recorded.
And I'd asked,
the guy said,
well,
what,
what is this about?
He said,
oh,
this is our proof to society to show them that we treated you nice before we
killed you.
And you said there are two guys,
what are these two?
Well,
both of these guard correction officers,
they just sit at the table d well these were the two that puts the change and
stuff on me and brought me to the death watch sale.
These were the same two guys that stopped me in front of the electric chair
said,
well and pull the sheet off of his ability.
We want you to see this and see that this is the chair that you're going to be
sitting in 72 hours from now and just look at it.
Explain how that happened.
They actually took her to the execution chamber,
right?
Instead of the two guys bringing me to the death watch sale out of the back door
of the captain's office,
which leads right to the sale.
So that's what cell block.
They took me all way around the prison and brought me into the viewing room
that,
uh,
the prosecutors or the victim's family or the defendant families come in and sit
and view the execution.
And so as we come into this room is just amazing to me because it looks like a
church.
You got pews on this side and deciding on a red carpet and as you walked down
the middle of this carpet,
there was a podium at the end and you can tell you that it's an electric chair
was under,
but it had a big white sheet over it.
So these two guys walked me right up to the chair and unexpectedly,
one guy just snatched the sheet off of is ability.
Look at this.
This is where you're going to be sitting in the next 72 hours.
And then they took you to the cell.
Then they took me to the death watch sale and put me in.
And uh,
the captain came by and he explains,
this is these,
these are your rights.
If you want to watch the television,
you tell them to turn it on cost.
It may be news about your case or any updates about your case.
Uh,
and same as with the radio or the newspapers.
But if you don't want these items on,
the guards won't turn them on.
They can't turn one unless you say so,
basically.
Right.
And so a lot of the time they're up until you got word obviously that you've got
to stay,
uh,
you spent your time visiting with people.
Uh,
just describe that.
Well,
the first part,
um,
I was sort of being somewhat terrorized by the guards because after the captain
left,
the guards asked me to turn the TVs on and I told him I wasn't watching the TV
that didn't care net and they're bad it.
So they said,
okay,
since you won't allow us to be entertained by the television,
then we will entertain you.
So they opened up their green log books and began to tell me what each of the 13
inmates who had been executed,
what they did it a line by line with how they move,
what they said,
what they did for the whole 72 hours.
And
this is the time leading up to each of their execution.
Yes.
The 72 hours at each one of them went through
live with each one.
I'm for at least 10 years,
knew him very well and that was really,
really disturbing to hear that.
And for them to even do something like that.
Why,
why would guards went to a terrorize you and
just to hear friends how they reacted and the things that they went through the
last 72 hours of their life.
And um,
tell us about your lawyers.
What was your,
you had a bad experience with your first lawyer.
You're fired him.
He took over your own case to do finally find some lawyers that you were
satisfied with.
Well,
yes.
The second lawyer that I had,
uh,
was from Athens law school and he came about because actually my mother in law,
she wrote the Naacp in New York.
She told them,
said,
listen,
I've been supporting you guys forever.
And my son in law was on death row.
He didn't have a lawyer.
Y'all going to help him where I'm coming to New York and there's going to be
some trouble up in,
in New York when she get there.
And so,
uh,
some kind of way.
They talked to Athens law,
uh,
law school at University of Georgia
law school at Athens.
Yeah.
And so I,
Laurie came by and he'd said,
yeah,
he's going to take,
he wanted to take the case.
And I said,
well,
you know,
before you do that,
I'm just not just giving it to anybody.
We're going to do this together.
And he was all agreeable.
So,
yeah.
And let me explain to you what we're going to do is we're going to lay the
foundation here in the state courts.
We're going to file all these issues so that when the state deny him,
because we know they are,
we'll have this when we get to the federal court.
And what happened is while the case was in the federal state courts,
uh,
there was a ruling from the federal court.
The made their office ended up with 250 state havens says he was just three
lawyers and so on.
My lawyer wrote me,
he said,
well,
I just can't do all this stuff I need to do with your case,
so I'm going to just drop.
He just dropped eight of the issues and I amended the issues back to the
petition and our petitions to the judge.
Uh,
let me fire him if he can't help me to where I needed to be.
he don't need to be on the case.
And so the judge would not let me fire him and actually had him come and they
had a hearing.
And out of all the issues,
I had the only argued one hearing and one issue.
And I tried to get up and talking to judge,
said the next time that I would say something and he'd have me gag because I'm
not a lawyer and I can argue it.
So that really,
really made me upset about attorneys and stuff.
And so I finally got him off the case and I was doing it myself until I got
attorney Dan [inaudible] from a northeastern university who came in in
[inaudible] 79 and began to help me out.
Dan [inaudible] was ultimately the dean.
Uh,
at northeastern law school.
Right.
When he first started,
he was just one of the professors and I think after two years when the case,
he became the dean and they have a death penalty clinic at the school.
So I guess a lot of his students was helping.
They working on my case and he was,
he really helped me though,
not just working on a case.
He really helped me as a person to rehabilitate me and from not liking and
lawyers because I just
didn't trust him.
Right,
right.
Because of all these bad experiences.
Right,
right.
And ultimately also John Charles Boger,
uh,
the head of the Naacp legal defense and Educational Fund became one of your
lawyers.
Right.
Because when I first started representing myself,
I wrote John Boger,
a row,
millet farmer and our,
I can't remember,
this other professor was in one of the law books I had.
Right.
And so I wrote him and they were giving me information and uh,
Jack and I got to be close and Jack Bogle,
we got to be close and he was giving me information and telling me what I should
do with this issue.
Or maybe it's just your might work.
It doesn't work.
And then in around,
I think like 83 he actually start assisting Dang available on your case.
It'd be good.
Cause your
ultimately actually was taken by the Supreme Court of the United States,
right?
Yes.
There was taking that as the cream some.
Yeah.
And,
and Jack Boger argued the case.
He argued before the Supreme Court and what the issues as a supreme court that
the state was pushing because I had gotten relief in the district court.
Right.
And lost the relief in 11th circuit.
So the argument at the Supreme Court became a successive petition.
That's what the argument was that I have filed a successive petition and had all
these other issues that I'm bringing late in.
Actually all the issues that they say I'm bringing late was in the initial
petition that judge Edenfield refused to hear when he granted me relief on the
first issue and he said he didn't have to look at the rest of them in the 11th
circuit,
agreed with him.
And so that caused the problem.
And so we were telling him to the Supreme Court,
we didn't abused a writ,
we didn't cause the problem.
The state caused the problem and we wouldn't be here if they would just say
went,
let me go back and had these other issues her because there was at least three
other issues within that group that was qualified enough to overturn the death
sentence.
And just so we're clear,
judge Edenfield was the United States district judge and he granted you relief
when you first were under death sons?
Yes.
And then you're a case went back and forth between panels of the 11 circuit that
is three judges on the United States Court of Appeals for the 11th circuit went
on box so that the entire 12 member court examined it all.
It only went to the supreme court.
But the Supreme Court,
after hearing the argument sent the case back without making a decision.
I said to consider it in light of another decision.
And ultimately,
uh,
you lost on,
on that decision at the 11th circuit.
Well,
yeah,
I lost,
I haven't,
but they never really heard it,
uh,
because the Supreme Court told them to look at it from the perspective of tig
versus lane,
the new case that they had decided on the year prior and when it went back to
the 11th circuit,
they didn't even look at that.
They went back to the issues of 1984 when I had the execution date.
And from there they just didn't denied.
And I got a new execution date for August the 22nd,
and uh,
that turned out to be the critical time,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Um,
on the 21st of August at 10 30 in the morning to assistant warden came,
I was in the visiting room and he told me that the United States Supreme Court
had given me a 30 day stay and I called my lawyer Dang developer and he said,
Yup,
we got a 30 day stay.
And you know,
since the court has my case,
the Georgia border part in paroles would not look at it because the case is
being reviewed by the Supreme Court because they never,
they never interfere with any of the courts there was looking at the case
because the pro board is like the rat last resort in Georgia anyway.
So we're like,
fine,
you know,
Supreme Court got it.
So I go back to the visiting room and while I'm in the visiting room that day,
somehow the parole board decided that they would hear my case and everybody
involved was notified and the victim's family came to the parole board on their
own without any coaching from anyone and said that we've been writing Billy for
the last 16 and a half years and he is our brother and you cannot kill him.
We lost one family member.
We don't want to lose another one as well as,
um,
my dad testifying and my sister,
even the first lawyer that I had,
he came and he testified and explained to the parole board why it was his
decision to plead me guilty.
Now he didn't tell the truth about his brother being a judge and all that.
The story he told them was that he felt,
because in Jefferson county there had been another robbery of a banker and his
wife,
they had been tortured and killed in your house was six months prior to my
crime.
And that the key felt that the county was still in such an uproar,
that nobody could get a fair trial that county.
It had.
I went to a jury,
I would have been sentenced to death and he said that was his reasoning and that
when he thought that by going directly to the judge,
he felt that the judge it understand that this is not a death penalty case and
would give me a life sentence.
But he didn't take any consideration nor understand that the sheriff ran the
county and at the sheriff told the judge is giving me a death sentence.
And that was it.
Uh,
also the judges are elected so the judge is going to stand for reelection after
he sends us you.
Yeah.
So that probably was a factor as well.
And I'm mother Theresa was also involved in the parole.
Yup.
A friend of mine named John Deere who was a high school student when I started
writing.
Yeah.
Had went to high school college and he became a Jesuit priests and he went and
spent a couple of years in India with Mother Teresa.
And so he was writing me from India and so she was well aware of my situation.
So John is back in the United States by this time and I got this new execution
date and he finds out,
so he calls her and asked her to call me.
I mean,
he caught a parole board and she tells him that,
well,
if they want to talk to her Dynisha call her.
Well,
I don't know how it came about,
but,
but they tell me since I was in a busy room and I had no idea it's,
this is happening,
that uh,
the chairman of the parole board stopped the hearing and had a press conference.
You said mother Theresa wanted to talk to him and he calls her and she tells him
that he needed to do what Jesus would do.
And then all five members of the parole board folk to commute my sentence from a
death sentence to her license.
Okay.
So suddenly you're no longer under death sin.
Yeah.
All of a sudden,
just,
just like that one day your death row inmate,
the next day you're not,
one day you're in chains.
You can't move anywhere without two guards.
The next day they give you a piece of paper and tell you to go to another part
of the person.
Yeah.
Now only that the,
when I got off death row,
uh,
one of the captains who used to work on death row came down to the cell block
that I was in and he told the guard,
the guard to bring me out of cell block.
And he said,
Billy,
you've been here 10 years and you have only seen death row.
He said,
you see this long hallway?
I'm over this hallway,
and he gave me a broom and he said,
he just got in this hall all day.
He said,
if anybody say anything to you,
you tell him,
come see me.
So I go from being locked up too.
Now I'm out in the hallway by myself up to nine o'clock at night,
just walking back and forth with a broom.
Now you said you'd been there 10 years.
That's because you started out on the old death row in Reidsville,
the Georgia state prison.
And then after six years it moves
to the Georgia diagnostic prison,
which is in Jackson,
Georgia.
While I'll stay in the county jail three years.
Right.
I was in the county jail three years in Reidsville,
three years and then we were all moved to Jackson.
Right,
right.
Let me just one other last pieces
does that hadn't been mentioned,
but,
but certainly should be a,
is your faith
and spirituality.
How,
how did that come into play in your case?
Well,
what happened when I was in the county jail,
my cousin wrote me a letter and she said,
Billy,
I know you have a death sentence and you need to accept Christ in your life
since you're going to be executed.
And so I'll flip it.
And I wrote her back and told her,
I don't,
you know,
I'm getting ready to die.
What I need to do this for.
Well,
she never wrote me back.
She just told her pastor in Ohio who called a pastor in Rome,
Georgia,
and this pastor and his wife drove 250 miles to the county jail,
didn't have an appointment,
didn't tell anybody who was coming.
Just showed up and in.
That's amazing to me because this sheriff was so mean.
He didn't let nobody do anything.
But however they convinced him to bring me downstairs from matter of fact,
he came upstairs personally and got me.
He said,
listen,
there's a preacher downstairs and went to see you.
And so when I came down,
uh,
Bishop Guthrie said,
listen,
son,
we know that you killed a man and that you've been sentenced to death,
but we want you to know that there was a just judge and his name is Jesus
Christ.
And God always does.
Right?
And He loves you.
And what really touched my heart was the fact that here's the people telling me
that even though you killed somebody,
God still loves you and we love you.
It's piece somebody who accepted me for me,
for,
for me,
being who I was at that point,
at the lowest point in my life.
And it made such an impact that it,
it changed my life.
And I said,
well,
what they have is what I need.
And accepting Christ changed my life dramatically.
Dropped dramatically.
And you actually taught Bible study classes while you were on death row?
Yeah.
Not only that,
teach Bible study classes I studied and I got a bachelor's degree while I was on
death row in theology.
But it helped me.
The only way you can do prison time is helping others because the more used to
thinking about yourself and think about your situation,
the harder it is,
the more you give out and help others,
the easier it is.
And,
and,
and actually it's that way in life too.
And so teaching a Bible class has really helped me because anytime you got to
teach somebody something,
you have to know more than what you know more than what you teach it.
He's got to know more on what they know.
So you have to study more.
And it really helped me and it gave me something quality to do and to see
inmates life change really,
really helped me.
And let me ask you this,
a year after the board committed your sentence from death to life imprisonment,
it parole to yes.
Which was,
which was a miracle.
Yeah,
a miracle in itself because when they said that they commuted the sentence,
they also said I have to serve 25 more years before they would think about
looking at my case.
Now let me ask you this,
to the minister who are Bishop Guthrie,
the person who first came to see you first got arrested.
Did he play any role once you were released?
What?
Not only once I was released,
but all through he constantly visit and he constantly wrote.
He never stopped.
And so the day that I got out he was there and they picked me up and took me up
to Rome.
Uh,
and by the time we got back to Rome,
it was like 11 o'clock at night and he took me to his house.
He said,
all right,
take those prison clothes off.
Did they give you,
and his is like the first suit I ever had in my life.
He gives me some about the same size,
give me some new shoes.
And he said,
all right,
come with me.
And then he takes me to the church and I'm trying to figure it out.
Who goes to church at like 11 o'clock at night and he said,
we're going into the church and it's dark,
you know,
so I'm still wondering what is going on.
And we go through the church into the saints,
into the sea,
the fellowship hall and airs like 300 people sitting there.
So he walked me up to the front and sits me over to the side and he start
talking to the people,
said,
listen,
uh,
I want you to know that we had been praying for Billy moral for the last 17 and
a half years.
And a lot of times we pray,
we don't see our answer are we prayed and we hope God too to give us an answer.
He said,
but I want you people to know that your prayers are answered because here's
Billy right here.
And he said,
I come here.
And from that point to this,
I've been talking to people.
That's how the,
that's how that started.
And he also gave you a job.
Yeah,
my job was his personal chauffeur.
How would you live in his house?
I lived in this house.
And you have basically been involved in a ministry ever since you were released.
Is that a fair statement?
Well,
it's a fair statement for me being bombed in Mr and the outside,
but I was involved in the ministry on the inside too.
Yeah.
So for the last almost four years I've been in ministry in trying to help people
know that the change that will really change somebody's got in their life.
All right,
Billy Moore,
thank you for coming and thank you for sharing a,
an a remarkable story of your time on death row and ultimately your commutation
and in the life you've lived in the community since that time.